Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Ma veramente vuoi cambiare lavoro?
Ma... scusami, ma dici sul serio?
Cioè, per i prossimi due anni
tu non guadagnerai una lira?
No.. aspetta, fammi capire:
tu veramente vuoi andare a lavorare
con un gruppo di uomini,
tutti tatuati, sudati,
che parlano solo di sesso,
e lasciare il tuo ufficio?
Mah... non so, certe volte
proprio non ti capisco.
Queste sono alcune delle cose
che mi sono state dette
quando ho deciso
di cambiare carriera.
Io ho una vita abbastanza particolare,
e sono molto felice di questo.
Ho iniziato in realtà
come procuratrice legale,
per poi passare per dieci anni di grafica
e poi finalmente laurearmi
in arti culinarie.
Le cose che ho fatto
prima di diventare cuoca,
in realtà, non le rinnego affatto:
anzi, sono molto contenta di averle fatte.
Poi, però, ho pensato
che forse la parte di me,
la parte creativa
che non avevo mai
sviluppato in precedenza,
è proprio quella in cui
potevo riuscire meglio.
E ne ho fatto davvero un goal:
ho detto, nella mia vita vorrò sempre
fare quello che mi piace,
perché secondo me, se una persona
fa quello che le piace,
è [quello] il vero lusso,
ed è sicuramente
la situazione in cui si riesce meglio.
Un paio di anni fa mi hanno chiesto
di scrivere un libro,
per cui ho pensato:
va bene, di cosa scrivo?
Sono una cuoca: ovviamente
la prima richiesta, quella più naturale,
era scrivere ricette.
Ho pensato: io non voglio
scrivere un libro di ricette.
Scrivere un libro di ricette
mi sembrava quasi banale.
Non che gli altri libri di ricette
lo fossero, tutt'altro;
ma ero io che non volevo,
volevo fare qualcosa di diverso.
Soprattutto perché,
in un campo maschile,
io ero riuscita a sfondare
determinate situazioni,
per cui volevo essere di esempio
a tante ragazze che volevano
intraprendere questo lavoro.
Considerate che io ogni giorno
ricevo tantissime poste elettroniche,
o telefonate, o addirittura tante ragazze
passano dal ristorante
e mi chiedono consiglio
e sento tantissime cose
che sono aberranti,
per certi versi.
Della serie, una ragazza di 24 anni
che vuole diventare cuoca
e le si dice:
oh, ma è troppo tardi!
Troppo tardi?!
Io ho cambiato carriera
quando avevo oltre 30 anni
e non ho avuto un attimo di dubbio
che la mia età potesse essere un ostacolo.
Era tutto qui dentro,
era quello che volevo fare
ed era quello che volevo
trasmettere nel mio libro.
Quindi ho messo giù una serie
di principi, e ho pensato:
be', forse questo potrà aiutare qualcuno.
Perché molte delle cuoche e delle chef
famosissime, bravissime, incredibili
a cui mi sono anche ispirata, precedenti,
generalmente hanno iniziato
la loro carriera perché il loro marito,
il loro padre, il loro fratello
- qualcuno in famiglia
aveva deciso di aprire un ristorante,
e loro si sono ritrovate in cucina.
Io invece volevo che la mia fosse
una scelta professionale differente.
I miei genitori non erano in questo mondo,
né tantomeno qualcuno vicino a me,
né tantomeno
mio marito, il mio compagno;
per cui volevo veramente iniziare da zero,
in un mondo in cui, in realtà,
non avevo nessuno che mi appoggiasse.
Non solo: questo paradossalmente
ha giocato a mio favore,
perché poi, specialmente quando
mi sono trasferita a Roma,
ho avuto tantissimi ospiti illustri,
giornalisti di cui non conoscevo nulla!
Quindi ho deciso di mettere giù
questi principi nel mio libro.
Queste sono le cinque regole,
perché secondo me,
tramite queste cinque regole,
we can unlock the future.
La prima: trova la forza
di essere diversa.
Questo è il mio principio fondamentale,
attraverso il quale ho vissuto
davvero tutta la mia vita,
e devo tutto a mia madre.
Perché mia madre
- sembra retorico, no?
sempre la mamma, o la nonna -
invece in realtà è proprio così.
Ma la cosa incredibile
è che i miei genitori
vengono da un paese piccolissimo:
mia madre è nata a Trinitapoli,
ha vissuto a Cerignola,
stiamo parlando del Profondo Sud,
specialmente di tantissimi anni fa.
Eppure, i miei genitori
mi hanno fatto fare
il primo viaggio all'estero,
quando avevo 14 anni, da sola.
Con un'organizzazione, ovviamente;
ma comunque da sola.
Incredibile, perché questo
mi ha aperto, secondo me,
un mondo che non pensavo esistesse.
Da lì è iniziata un'educazione diversa,
un modo di vedere le cose diverso,
e soprattutto un abbracciare
le altre culture diverse.
E questo lo devo a mia madre,
che mi ha sempre detto:
ricordati che la vera forza
è quella di essere diversa.
Io lo vedo con mio figlio,
che ora ha sette anni.
Ho sempre parlato inglese,
da quando è nato:
eppure mi risponde in italiano.
A un certo punto ho iniziato
a preoccuparmi:
ma perché io gli parlo in inglese,
e lui mi risponde in italiano?
Per cui, parlando
con una psicologa, mi ha detto:
no, è proprio questo,
è il principio del peer pressure.
E ho iniziato a pensare:
tutti i bambini vogliono
essere uguali agli altri!
Così mi è stato spiegato,
e poi ho pensato:
tutte le donne fanno così.
Tutte le donne vogliono essere
uguali alle altre!
Ci vestiamo nella stessa maniera,
parliamo nella stessa maniera,
guardiamo le stesse cose in tv,
vogliamo anche fare gli stessi lavori!
Non è questo: il vero lusso,
il vero momento
in cui we can unlock the future
è quando noi ritroveremo noi stesse
e faremo esattamente quello che vorremo.
Ed è questa la strada
che io ho cercato di seguire
durante tutta la mia vita.
Allora ho pensato
- sempre nel libro -
come posso pensare,
per esempio, ad un piatto,
perché ovviamente io vivo in questo mondo,
quindi dovevo in ogni caso illustrare
un principio con un piatto.
Questo è uno dei piatti storici,
fatto nel 2006.
Voi direte, vabbè è un panino,
ok, ho capito.
Cosa c'è di strano?
Nel 2006, nessuno parlava di panini.
Nessuno ha mai servito un panino,
soprattutto in un ristorante
che poi ha ricevuto la stella Michelin.
Tant'è vero che,
quando andai dal mio socio
e dissi: sai, io voglio mettere
questo piatto in carta.
È un panino alla liquirizia,
con una scaloppa di fois gras
e un finto ketchup di mango
e una maionese al passito
con delle patatine fritte.
Lui mi guardò, e disse:
questa è matta!
Perché io non so se riuscirei a farlo...
ma veramente
vuoi mettere un panino?
Io veramente voglio mettere
un panino.
Perché secondo me è la maniera
per fare un crossover,
praticamente cercare di identificare
un modo di ristorazione
diverso rispetto a quello del passato.
Il nostro ristorante, che ho a Roma,
è un ristorante che ha ricevuto
la stella Michelin,
ed è nato 11 anni fa senza tovaglie.
Cosa che oggi - insomma,
oggi si va nei ristoranti
e non ci sono, le tovaglie:
ma un progetto di 12 anni fa,
con un'apertura di 11 anni fa,
senza tovaglie,
era già una grossa evoluzione:
la cucina doveva seguire lo stesso ritmo,
e doveva seguire la stessa linea!
Ed è per questo che,
quando sono entrata lì dentro,
mi sono sentita a casa,
e ho detto:
questo è il posto
dove io posso esprimere me stessa.
E non sono uguale alle altre:
l'ho sempre pensato,
e continuerò a pensarlo.
Ma io penso che ognuno di noi
dovrebbe pensare una cosa del genere.
Il secondo principio è,
sappi sempre dove andare.
Perché, vedete, le donne
- questa è un'altra cosa
che non facciamo spesso:
molte volte non abbiamo
il coraggio di dichiarare a noi stesse
dove vogliamo andare.
Un po' perché abbiamo paura,
un po' soprattutto, e spesso,
pensiamo di non esserne capaci,
o di non meritarcelo.
È facile sentire un uomo che,
parlando con il proprio capo, dice:
io, in un anno, voglio diventare
capo di questo reparto.
Ne ho sentito proprio uno,
ieri, in treno.
Ho mai sentito una donna, dire una cosa
di questo genere? No.
Quando invece la si sente, purtroppo,
e questo è statisticamente provato
tramite studi,
quando una donna afferma determinate cose
purtroppo le accezioni
sono più negative che positive.
Quando le dice un uomo sono positive;
quando le dice una donna sono negative.
Allora ho pensato: io voglio sapere
dove voglio andare,
voglio sapere chi vorrò essere
in un anno, due anni,
tanto è vero
che quando ho cambiato carriera
mi sono data dieci anni di tempo.
Ho detto: se in dieci anni
non riesco a sfondare,
ok, tornerò a fare qualcos'altro.
Ho due lauree, parlo tre lingue,
un lavoro lo troverò.
E quindi mi sono detta,
sempre parlando del libro:
cosa posso fare, qual è il piatto
che voglio accoppiare
a questo principio?
Ed è questo.
Questo è il piatto che mi ha portato
in giro per il mondo.
È un pastrami di lingua.
Voi direte: vabbé,
un pastrami di lingua...
Il pastrami in realtà è ebreo,
quindi io sono andata
negli Stati Uniti,
a New York, sono andata
in tre posti molto famosi
e ho studiato
come si faceva il pastrami.
Sono tornata a Roma, e ho applicato
ad un pezzo di carne
che è tipico della tradizione laziale
-volevo onorare in fondo il posto
dove io sono tornata
e che mi ha dato
tanta felicità e tanto lusso
in questi ultimi dieci anni -
e quindi ho fatto
questo pastrami di lingua,
prima ancora che la parola pastrami
o le tecniche di pastrami
divenissero di nuovo comuni.
Infatti mi fa molto piacere
quando io faccio una cosa
con due anni in anticipo,
poi diventa famosa:
significa che sono sulla strada giusta.
E questo è un piatto che è stato
presentato a Identità golose,
un convegno al quale ho avuto la fortuna
di partecipare, in passato,
e che ha veramente informazioni
incredibili riguardo proprio a noi donne,
[il] perché ora ve lo spiego.
Terzo principio: rispetta te stessa
e il mondo in cui vivi.
Importantissimo principio,
perché soprattutto attraverso
il rispetto di noi stesse
possiamo raggiungere
i nostri obiettivi.
Prima parlavo di identità golosa:
sono stata la prima speaker donna
che sia stata chiamata
sul palco centrale a parlare.
Per cui mi sono detta:
di cosa parlo?
Perché secondo me c'è una responsabilità
nei confronti di chi,
- quando ci viene chiesto
di che cosa parlare -
nei confronti di chi ci ascolta.
E ho pensato: il principio del rispetto
era quello che dominava quel convegno.
E io ho detto: ok,
io parlerò della fermentazione.
Sono stata - mi vanto di essere stata
la prima a parlare
di fermentazione in un convegno.
E lo sapete perché l'ho fatto?
Mi ricordava, in un certo senso,
la nostra vita.
Io ho parlato del kimchi,
della tecnica del kimchi.
È un cavolo: eppure la fermentazione,
con il nostro controllo
e con la nostra passione e la nostra cura,
dà la possibilità, all'ingrediente,
di raggiungere
il massimo esponenziale possibile.
Quel cavolo è diventato kimchi,
ed è una cosa
assolutamente di una bontà unica,
oltre a far bene.
Eppure non è stato fatto
nulla di straordinario:
c'erano le condizioni giuste
perché questo potesse accadere.
Ed è questo che mi ha attratto tantissimo
della fermentazione:
ho associato immediatamente
la tecnica di fermentazione al rispetto:
al rispetto dell'ingrediente,
ma anche al rispetto di noi stesse.
È fondamentale avere rispetto
di noi stesse,
attraverso le proprie azioni.
Questo è uno dei principi
che mi piace di più,
potete notarlo dai miei capelli:
pushing the envelope,
contro gli stereotipi della donna
(in cucina e fuori).
Sono sempre stata una persona
che non ha mai creduto
- o meglio, ha sempre pensato
di dover sfondare determinati stereotipi.
Lo so, ora dirò una cosa
che probabilmente vi farà sorridere,
specialmente alle nuove generazioni.
Quando io mi sono laureata
in giurisprudenza,
ho voluto mettermi
un paio di pantaloni
per andare a discutere la tesi.
La mia famiglia era
terrorizzata, scandalizzata:
vuoi mettere un paio di pantaloni?!
Sì, voglio mettere
un paio di pantaloni.
Non era normale che una donna
si mettesse un paio di pantaloni
per andare a discutere la propria tesi.
Da quel momento in poi ho sempre fatto,
ho sempre cercato
di andare controcorrente.
Se qualcosa era necessario,
o socialmente accettato,
ed era, appunto,
quasi uno stereotipo,
io ho cercato di sfondarlo.
Anche nel momento in cui
ho deciso, autonomamente,
di intraprendere una carriera
completamente diversa
rispetto a quella della mia famiglia.
Il piatto che vi ho associato,
e questo è l'ulitmo piatto:
considerate che è stato,
probabilmente,
il piatto più fotografato
di questo convegno
e associato a quest'anno.
Io sono una promotrice
della difesa delle api
e quindi, anche,
di tutto ciò che ne deriva,
in questo caso il miele.
Ho associato, ho fatto un piccolo gioco
(una trippa a nido d'ape)
e nello stesso tempo
ha una salsa a base
di idromiele e miele.
Ed è una rivisitazione
di una zuppa messicana.
Questo piatto mi ha portato
tanta fortuna, quest'anno,
e mi ha fatto scoprire
che ci sono tantissime cose
che noi donne possiamo fare bene:
non meglio degli uomini -
perché io non credo nella esclusione,
ma credo nella inclusione:
apro e chiudo una parentesi,
le società più resistenti
sono le società inclusive,
non quelle esclusive.
Quindi io ritengo invece
di essere un esempio,
spero di essere un esempio
per coloro che vogliono
intraprendere questa carriera.
In poche parole,
cos'è che voglio dire?
Io voglio dire a tutte le donne,
soprattutto a quelle che stanno iniziando,
[che] questa carriera
- ma non soltanto
quella nell'ambito della cucina,
ma in tutte le carriere -
che è arrivato il momento
che.. we unlock the future for real.
Noi dobbiamo credere in noi stesse,
perché noi possiamo:
siamo intelligenti, siamo capaci,
possiamo dirlo ad alta voce.
E sarebbe arrivato il momento
che lo facciamo per davvero.
(Applausi)